elle turbines au gré du vent problème
l'énergie produite par les éoliennes
près de fantôme elle n'est pas constante
en cas de vents forts il y un surplus
d'électricité sur le réseau pour
équilibrer ses variations
rte vient d'installer en côte d'or son
premier centre de batteries de stockage
quand il y a de façon intermittente à
beaucoup d'énergie éolienne on ne peut
pas toujours l'évacuer par le réseau
électrique
donc il peut être judicieux plutôt que
de construire de nouveaux ouvrages par
exemple d'avoir un lieu de stockage qui
va nous permettre de ne pas perdre ce
surplus d'électricité de le restituer
quand pourra être évacués par le réseau
ou quand tu auras la consommation à
proximité pour pour l'utiliser dix
containers sont installés sur le site
ils permettront de collecter et
restituer à la seconde près 24 mégawatts
d'électricité l'équivalent de la
consommation d'une ville de 10 mille
habitants tout est autonome on comptera
c'est honteux suis tout ça à distance et
sur l'ensemble on enregistre près de
20000 donné à la seconde pour surveiller
l'ensemble de fonctionnement des
batteries avantages de cette solution
modulable des travaux de mise en service
plus simple et une meilleure sécurité en
cas de dysfonctionnement ça permet de
préfabriqués donc de diminuer l'inter le
temps d'intervention sur site
et puis dans une optique de sécurité
d'installations
on a des systèmes qui sont beaucoup plus
cloisonnés que si on devait installer
l'ensemble des batteries dans un
bâtiment 24 millions d'euros ont été
investis sur le site de fontenelle un
site qui sera rejoint en 2021 par deux
autres en haute vienne et dans les
hautes-alpes
ils devront s'échanger en permanence les
flux d'énergie de façon autonome
ce serait alors une première mondiale